is there something else that you've been
excited about like reusable rockets
perhaps that you've seen in the last few
years
well the reusability you had your
usability is awesome I mean this is the
best now we have to remember the shuttle
was a reusable vehicle yes
which an shuttle is an amazing aerospace
engineer I mean the shuttle is still
this the most gorgeous elegant
extraordinary design of a space vehicle
it was reusable it just wasn't
affordable but the reusability of it was
really critical because we flew it up it
did come back so the notion of usability
and I think absolutely now what we're
doing with we you know a global we but
with SpaceX of origin sending the
Rockets up recovering the first stages
where if they can regain 70% cost
savings that's huge and just seeing the
control you know the convenient control
and dynamics person is just seeing that
rocket come back and land oh yeah that's
it never gets old it's exciting so it's
so cool give me the landing is when I
stand up start clapping just just the
control control I goes and hit that
landing it's you know it's gymnastics
for her for a rocket ship veteran see
these guys stick a landing or foot it's
just wonderful so every time like I said
every time I see ya the reusability and
the rockets coming back and landing so
precisely it's really exciting so it is
it is actually that's a game-changer we
are in a new era of lower costs and a
lot the higher frequency and it's it's
the world not just NASA it's many
nations are really upping their
frequency of launches
you